[Music]
ingrid visser and keniscolet
are looking for evidence that orca are
hunting great white sharks
in new zealand waters ingrid has
evidence
that there's a disturbing pattern in
orca hunting
new zealand orca are hunting sevengill
sharks
just like the south african orca
sevengill sharks grow to nine feet long
and 200 pounds
a much larger meal for an orca than a
small ray
but the sevengill shark is no easy prey
sevengills are relatively new on the
orca menu
but i've seen it a few times now you see
the orca and they're
very very precise in how they do it i've
got footage of orca with the sevengills
where they've ripped the pectoral fin
right under the pectoral girdle there
and and they've extracted the liver
[Music]
one of the things i find fascinating is
how the seven girls will actually turn
and defend themselves against the orca
the way the orca hunt the sevengills is
pretty impressive
first of all they'll come in and they'll
karate chop the sharks so they'll just
come and lift their tail up and whack
them on the back
then they grab the sharks by the
pectoral fin and rip them open
and pull the livers out
ingrid captured rare footage of orcas
hunting sevengills in northern new
zealand
their precision in hunting for shark
liver is clear
[Music]
you